en el vídeo anterior nos fijamos en la
estructura de puntos del dióxido de
azufre y vimos que tienen dos
estructuras resonantes verdad el que
tenemos del lado izquierdo y el que
tenemos del lado derecho y algunas
personas no estaban de acuerdo conmigo y
dicen que no es la estructura de puntos
del dióxido de azufre que en realidad es
la siguiente tenemos el azufre con un
doble enlace al oxígeno digamos que está
del lado izquierdo y bueno este oxígeno
por supuesto tendrá dos parejas de
electrones solitarios muy bien y este
también tiene un doble enlace con otro
oxígeno que también tiene dos parejas de
electrones solitarios y finalmente lo el
azufre tiene una pareja de electrones
solitarios muy bien entonces el punto de
este vídeo será discutir qué tantas
diferencias hay entre estas dos
estructuras y lo primero que podemos ver
en esta estructura que tenemos abajo y
es que tiene una ventaja y no tiene no
hay cargas formales ni para el azufre ni
para el oxígeno verdad entonces
realmente esta es una estructura válida
pero si nos fijamos en el azufre vamos a
observar algo interesante este azufre
tiene alrededor digamos aquí tenemos dos
electrones cuatro electrones 6
electrones 8 electrones y tenemos otros
2 de esta pareja solitaria de electrones
verdad entonces lo que estamos
observando en esta estructura es que el
azufre tiene una capa extendida de
valencia una capa de valencia extendida
muy bien quizás es la forma más adecuada
de llamarlo la capa de valencia
extendida y eso lo único que nos dice es
que tiene más de 8 electrones verdad en
este caso tiene 10 y esto es correcto
pues el azufre se encuentra en el en el
tercer periodo de la tabla periódica y
tiene algunos orbitales de ahora vamos a
analizar esta estructura que teníamos
antes digamos vamos a estudiar la
estructura resonante de la
derecha y ahora si nos fijamos en el
azufre este tiene 24
y 8 electrones alrededor es decir este
azufre cumple la regla del octeto muy
bien ahora lo único que estamos
observando es que este azufre tiene una
carga formal positiva mientras que el
oxígeno tiene una carga formal negativa
verdad entonces la única comparación que
tenemos entre estas dos estructuras es
que la de arriba cumple la regla del
octeto pero posee cargas formales una
positiva para el azufre y una negativa
para el oxígeno
en cambio la estructura que tenemos
abajo no tiene cargas formales pero
tiene una capa de valencia extendida muy
bien entonces cuál de ellas es la
correcta esa es la pregunta que queremos
resolver en este vídeo y la respuesta
que yo creo es que ambas son correctas
verdad por ejemplo vamos vamos a
recordar que en realidad esto representa
a una estructura híbrida verdad por
ejemplo esto tiene un enlace doble
mientras que aquí hay un enlace simple
verdad entonces en realidad estamos
diciendo que el dióxido de azufre
no está representado por ninguna de
estas dos sino es un híbrido verdad
tenemos aquí el azufre y por ejemplo si
observamos el enlace del lado izquierdo
que hay aquí tenemos un doble enlace
mientras que del lado derecho tenemos un
enlace simple entonces si tenemos un
enlace simple aquí tenemos ese enlace
pero el otro lo ponemos con una línea
punteada lo cual nos representa que es
digamos un estado híbrido entre un
enlace doble y un enlace simple ahora si
nosotros analizamos el otro enlace aquí
tenemos un enlace simple y aquí tenemos
un enlace doble así que también lo
representamos como una línea sólida y
una línea punteada representando
nuevamente que es un estado híbrido
entre un enlace simple y un enlace doble
y eso está muy bien porque
experimentalmente se ha observado que
tienen la misma longitud y es lo que
muestra esta representación híbrida muy
bien así que en mi opinión ambas
estructuras son correctas de hecho
busquen
los libros de texto y algunos dan la
respuesta bueno dicen que la respuesta
correcta es esta estructura que tenemos
arriba sin embargo logré también
encontrar otros libros en donde dicen
que la correcta es la estructura que
tenemos abajo ok así que lo mejor para
cuando tenemos este tipo de casos es
usar cálculos cuánticos pero eso va más
allá del objetivo de este vídeo así que
si te fijas muy bien de hecho ambas
estructuras dan geometría angular así
que más bien dependerá del gusto de tu
profesor pero en mi opinión ambas
estructuras son correctas y no tiene
mucho sentido debatir más al respecto